liebes rtl schlechte nachrichten wir
haben ein gamer der so gar nicht in euer
klischee passt er ist locker und
entspannt er hat eine freundin ist
trotzdem erfolgreich beim games und
seine freundin hat er beim gamen oder
durch scannen kennengelernt das und mehr
jetzt im talk viel spaß dabei
denn ist die lage sehr sehr gut also
schönes wetter
ich habe mich ein bisschen erholt von
dem turnier am wochenende für mich auch
wieder ein bisschen besser ich war ja
recht niedergeschlagen dass ich nur
zweiter geworden bin und doch so weit
alles gut vor allen dingen sockel kam er
aus dem lower bracket wie heißt also aus
quasi zum verlierer fällt ja wer es
nicht weiß und da du eben aus dem gewinn
abfällt und eigentlich jetzt du ja daher
mathematisch oder theoretisch gewinnen
müssen aber da hast nahezu alles
verloren ja also ich habe ja vorher
gegen ihn gewonnen genau dann geht man
aktiv mit ein bisschen rückenwind in die
letzte partie aber man darf nie
vergessen es
ist halt wirklich jeder darum zu
gewinnen und socke ist ein sehr sehr
starker spieler also der weiß was er
macht ist vielleicht sogar antiken
stärker als ich und daher wusste ich
schon dass sehr sehr schwierig wird ich
muss aber auch sagen dass ich halt
verhältnismäßig schwächer gespielt habe
als in den vorherigen runden woran es
lag weiß ich nicht vielleicht war
einfach schon die energie so ein
bisschen weg am ende des tages
kommt vor sollte nicht vorkommen aber es
passiert halt leider wie ist das bei so
einem spiel ist das mit man kennt diese
interviews immer mit sportlern nach
sportwettbewerben ist das ähnlich bei
euch dass man wirklich auch so dieser
herr ich momentan nicht gut drauf und ja
oder ich hatte keine ahnung was in dem
verletzung von verletzungen meistens
nicht aber also bei uns wenn es so hat
man immer im sinne von der verletzung
dann sind es halt so lex oder disconnect
also wenn was mit den pcs nicht stimmt
oder mit dem netzwerk damit haben wir
halt ab und zu zu kämpfen und ansonsten
sind es auch die typischen fragen was
lief schief warum hast du verloren sind
natürlich alles sachen die man erst mal
nicht hören möchte
ja ich denke schon dass es da sehr
ähnlich wie im sport und
direkt nach der niederlage ist meistens
sehr sehr schwer zu analysieren was
schieflief weil man da ja auch mal so
ein bisschen emotional mit drin steckt
und nach ein paar stunden weiß man immer
recht genau woran es lag und dann kann
man daran auch arbeiten
als wir mit dem ganzen angefangen hast
hast du dir mal vorstellen können dass
wir auf einer bühne sitzt pc spiele
spielst und ist die siegerehrung am
schluss geht nein also damals als ich
angefangen habe wusste ich auch
überhaupt gar nicht dass ich den sport
liebt aber haben wir uns schon alles
angefangen hast also sehr klar die szene
waren auch riesen also ist ja jetzt
immer noch sehr klein aber die szene war
damals noch sehr viel kleiner und
damals als ich weiß nicht 15 16 da habe
ich schon viel gespielt also vor zehn
jahren ungefähr ja genau ja ungefähr ich
bin jetzt 24
da war es dann eigentlich einfach nur
aus spaß und man ist einem kleinen team
beigetreten online oder online gespielt
dann hat man so kleine kinos gespielt
also zwei teams gegeneinander und da war
nichts mit sponsoren nichts mit
preisgeld nichts mit großer bühne das
wurde von zu hause gespielt dann war das
fertig und dann ist man offline gegangen
und habe was anderes gemacht und ich bin
da auch einfach irgendwie reingerutscht
dass es war nie meine intention die
sportler zu werden oder so es ist
einfach gekommen ich kann irgendwann den
anruf bekommen ob ich denn mal unter
vertrag spielen möchte oder das ganze
ein bisschen professioneller machen
möchte und da war ich halt schon sehr
bach das ist das überhaupt gibt und habe
aber gedacht ich probier's mal aus und
bin hängen geblieben
wie sind sie sich denn damals auf dich
gekommen
also man spielt ja online und da gibts
halt ranglisten und ich war immer sehr
hoch in den ranglisten auch zu der zeit
wo ich halt noch in keinem team wirklich
gespielt habe und ich denke mal einfach
die haben sich da so ein bisschen
umgeschaut
sicherlich keine talentscouts aber sie
wussten halt der ist deutscher der hat
kein team der spiele entscheiden ganz
gut dann können wir ja mal fragen ob er
lust hat und so ist der kontakt damals
zustande gekommen mit meinem team bei
mousesports bin ich jetzt immer noch und
ja wie gesagt es war halt wirklich nie
die intention ich habe einfach viel
gespielt gerne gespielt und dann
scheinen auch recht gut und dann hat
sich das so entwickelt was hat sich
seitdem geändert sehr viel also es ist
sehr viel professioneller geworden
ich besuche sehr sehr viele events ich
gebe sehr viele interviews zum beispiel
das training ist professioneller
geworden also früher war es ja wirklich
nur eine spielzeit ich habe sehr viel
einfach nur gespielt ohne mir wirklich
gedanken zu machen das hat sich sehr
verändert man analysiert sehr viel seine
eigenen fehler man analysiert die
spielstile seiner gegner guckt ob man da
irgendwas ausnutzen kann ob irgendwelche
schwächen hat also das training hat sich
sehr verändert und insgesamt man fährt
halt sehr sehr viel auf events und es
ist einfach größer geworden oder ist
nimmt auch mehr zeit in anspruch und
hört sich so an als wäre der struktur
rein gekommen die vorher gar nicht sogar
definitiv ist definitiv strukturen
kommen ja es ist manchmal immer noch so
ein bisschen larifari aber es ist besser
geworden also was ich mich auch schon
gewundert ja der hat sie vielleicht auf
die taktik seines gegners ich richtig
eingestellt oder der hat das vielleicht
besser beobachtet und dass das geht
alles schon eine wichtige rolle
definitiv ich und ich glaube auch jetzt
mal zum finale zurück zu kommen ich
denke das sollte sich einfach ein
bisschen besser auf mich eingestellt hat
und einfach ein bisschen besser in
richard er wusste ein bisschen genauer
was auf ihn zukommt und dann kann man
sich natürlich sehr gut drauf einstellen
und dementsprechend halt spielen ja was
sagt dein umfeld das wahrscheinlich ja
nicht wie sports betreibt dazu also
familie freunde schule keine ahnung
genau mein freundeskreis
da ist eigentlich nur ein einziger dabei
der auch recht viel spielt alle anderen
so gut wie gar nichts mit gaming zu tun
oder halten nur sehr wenig mal am
wochenende vielleicht mal eine runde
fifa oder so
die unterstützen mich kommen auch ab und
zu zu den events fans hier in köln ist
verstehen uns zwar nicht wirklich was
auf der bühne passiert aber es sind halt
trotzdem am start und versuchen nicht zu
unterstützen und verfolgen so ein ganz
bisschen die szene also sie wissen auf
welchen turnieren ich bin wo auch
meistens sie wissen auch wie es
ausgegangen ist aber sie gucken sich
halt die spiele nicht an und meine
familie
besonders meine eltern waren am anfang
sehr kritisch was das anging damals als
ich noch jünger war besonders als dann
die ersten reisen kam und ich flog dann
alleine ich glaube das erste was san
francisco die vier jahren mit 16 war ist
erst einmal da und meine mutter
hatte schon so ein bisschen angst weil
erstens wusste sie überhaupt nicht was
ich da wirklich mache also ich habe
gesagt ich flieg dahin zu um zu spielen
das war schon mal ein bisschen feld
sagen und dann flog ich natürlich allein
das war ein paar leute dabei aber die
kannte ich ja auch nicht direkt und als
ich dann unbeschadet nach hause gekommen
bin und sie gemerkt habe dass ich spaß
hatte und
dass ich auch ganz gut bin also dass sie
ab und zu mal gewinne hat sich das dann
so ein bisschen geändert hieß es solange
die schulischen leistungen stimmen
kannst du das weitermachen und rechts
hätte hier angegriffen und welchen spiel
kommt das ist eine art
und ja sie mein vater war da nie so
kritisch aber wie gesagt dann haben sie
mich unterstützen mich auf und stehen
jetzt auch hinter mir und gucken
tatsächlich auch teilweise die streams
nein auch wenn ich glaube weil sie
nichts verstehe die verstehen noch
weniger als mein freundeskreis ja aber
sie gucken kann sich zu meine mutter
ganz süß sie sagt dann immer ja sie hat
die ganze zeit daumen gedrückt und ist
auch ganz nervös weil sie hört dann ja
die kommentatoren und
wenn es ein bisschen hektisch zugeht und
die dann sagen aber das war nicht so gut
von mir dann viel hat sie auch mal
richtig wird also ja gucken auf jeden
fall zu und die schulischen leistungen
habe auch nicht abgenommen nein ich habe
ich mussten ihn ja wiederholen ich habe
mein abitur ganz normal gemacht dass ich
war vorher auf eine realschule hat dann
mein abitur im nachhinein gemacht in der
nach köln gezogen für studium und
mache aber im moment
eine pause weil starcraft 2 so viel zeit
in anspruch nimmt das ist nicht so
wirklich unter einen hut passt und es
macht mir sehr viel spaß stehen im
moment recht erfolgreich und ich möchte
das einfach mitnehmen und ich weiß noch
nicht genau wie lange aber das studium
wird danach auf jeden fall beendet das
heißt wie lange hast du dieses semester
studiert also werden sie pause gemacht
hat es im 43 da machst du auch in
vorlesungen und ich habe ich hätte auf
jeden fall mehr machen können also es
war schon es wäre auf jeden fall ja es
hätte auch so oder so bisschen länger
gedauert als die als die
regelstudienzeit keine frage und ja es
wird jetzt auf jeden fall bisschen
länger dauern und
verdienste denn dann lädt die sports so
gut dass du dass das ein perspektive
vielleicht auch ist also das ist erstens
ich kann es vielleicht mal länger machen
und oder ich verdiene hier so viel dass
ich dann dass ich dann später ein
bisschen luft darüber wie ist das also
die sache ist ich habe mein studium
schon immer damit finanziert auch als
ich nach vermietung bin also auch die
wohnung usw das habe ich durch den
export finanziert man wird nicht reicht
damit
und als starcraft 2 herausgekommen ist
ist es insgesamt besser geworden es gibt
mehr turniere mehr preisgelder die teams
report nein auch ein wenig besser und es
ist im moment schon recht lukrativ aber
dass ich jetzt sagen würde ich mache es
jetzt auf unbestimmte zeit einfach so
weiter
kann ich im moment nicht zu sagen es ist
ganz schwer zu
wissen wie sich das halt entwickelt also
wie viel größer der s-bahn an sich noch
wird es
gibt ja auch noch nicht so viele posten
also die meisten die wiesbaden arbeiten
sind spieler oder vielleicht
kommentatoren dann gibt es noch ein paar
die management tätig sind aber so
trainer usw das ganze drumherum das gibt
es ja eigentlich noch nicht und da bin
ich halt sehr gespannt darauf wie sich
das in den nächsten jahren entwickelt
das heißt davon macht auch abhängig ob
du noch weiter studierst und genau es
könnte sein dass ich im sport einfach
erhalten bleibe
aber da gibt es keine konkreten
planungen also da schauen wir mal wie es
dann aussieht und gehen du studierst
wenn ich richtig der
wirtschaftsmathematik ist ich habe
wirtschaftsinformatik studiert schafft's
informatik
und das warum hast du das studium
gewählt ist ist gaming so was was in
diese richtung geht ist das was war zwar
völlig unabhängig von guerrilla genauso
das hat mit meinem mit meinem gaming
eigentlich zu tun die wahl einfach so
getroffen okay diese zeit opferst du
jetzt oder hatten nimmst du dir für den
spot wie muss man da jeden tag acht
stunden trainieren oder
könnte man auf jeden fall man also ich
persönlich bin da immer relativ foul
also ich könnte mehr trainieren als ich
vielleicht hat es wegen verloren
vielleicht ja sogar der socke ist auch
sehr froh
dass mal kurz anzusprechen
also es ist bei mir ist das immer so ich
gucke an welches turnier ansteht wie ist
das teilnehmerfeld wie ist das preisgeld
und wenn ich mir reelle chancen
ausrechnen also ich weiß da sind nicht
zum beispiel zu viele koreaner da die
halt schon noch ein stück besser sind
als wir dann wird schon sehr viel
trainiert dann sind es halt teilweise
schon die acht stunden am tag
wobei wie gesagt nicht nur reine
spielzeit sondern auch sehr viel analyse
dabei man unterhält sich mit anderen
spielern über strategien und taktiken
und ich würde sagen im durchschnitt 23
stunden am tag spielzeit und man guckt
sich sachen an und
dann wie gesagt wenn turniere anstehen
ist es schon sehr viel mehr ist kann
auch über acht stunden gehen auf jeden
fall was ist das ist das eine ist das
hobby ist das ein großer spaß ist das
ein beruf ist dass in dem beruf auch im
sinne von berufung was ist das was du da
machst ist finger als hobby an jetzt im
moment würde ich ja fast sagen es ist
mein beruf weil ich immer noch so also
das gefühl habe dass ich arbeite ist
wirklich nur auf turnieren also wenn ich
auf events bin wenn ich nicht zu hause
bin dann habe ich das gefühl
hier muss ich wirklich was leisten ist
sehr wichtig dass ich die leistung
bringe dann geht man auch früher ins
bett geht nicht feiern und so weiter
wenn ich zu hause trainiere ist schon
immer noch so ein bisschen
es ist dann einfach mein hobby so das
mache ich gern ich tatsächlich spaß dran
deswegen schwierige frage ich es ist ein
hobby was im moment zum beruf geworden
ist glauben fühlst du dich denn manchmal
ein bisschen außen vor weil du sagst ja
deine freunde haben nichts damit zu tun
da eine family gehabt nichts damit zu
tun also ist das etwas was man so viel
sicherheit wie ich sage mal mineralien
sammeln oder
die sommer wenn man musik macht dann
steht man irgendwie im leben weil die
leute wissen was musik machen ist die
wissen was die gitarre ist was ein
klavier ist aber was ihr da oben oben
auf dem schirm weil den esl hat man
immer eine große projekt so was ihr da
macht das kann ja kaum einer
nachvollziehen was wir schon beschrieben
hast das ist tatsächlich so also der
großteil der gespräche also über das
spiel weiter findet dann auch mit
anderen spielern statt es ist selten
dass ich mein nach hause kommen wir also
mein bruder kennt sich da auch so ein
bisschen aus der weiß halt dann auch was
passiert es in den spielen warum ich
gewonnen und verloren hat mit dem kann
ich da auch darüber reden aber so mein
freundeskreis an sich und meine eltern
da ist dann nur ok gewonnen oder
verloren gut gespielt gratulation so was
halt in dem sinne
also ich würde nicht sagen dass mich das
stört ich finde sogar eigentlich recht
angenehm dass wir nach dem turnier nach
hause kommt man nicht die ganze zeit
darüber reden muss weil man einfach mal
auch abschalten möchte und es stört mich
nicht wirklich
macht man sich damit ein bisschen zum
außenseiter oder zum nerd oder so weil
das ja so was für einen selbst ist oder
ist man anders noch gemeiner gefragt
macht es einsam nein also nicht
persönlich also aus meiner persönlichen
erfahrung nein
ich denke schon dass ich also hört
sicherlich ich denke wenn jemand so
exzessiv oder so viel zeit investiert
dann ist man da auf jeden fall nerd ob
es jetzt positiv oder negativ ist muss
jeder selber wissen aber einsam nein
also man lernt sehr viel leute kennen
also man reist er sehr viel man
reist ja auch aus demselben grund also
man fliegt irgendwo hin um dann stark
aufzuspielen das heißt man teil sein
hobby mein teil vor ort auch dieselbe
aktivität also
man hat da schon sehr also es ist schon
man ist da gemeinsam unterwegs man reist
ja auch viel zusammen die spieler
untereinander verstehen sie sich
größtenteils alle sehr sehr gut dass es
gibt da nur wenig zickereien und so
weiter und ich würde nicht sagen was man
einsam wird wobei man ja auch den e
sport und wirklich jemanden der einfach
nur aus hobby spielt das ist ja ein
großer unterschied also wenn jetzt ich
weiß nicht wenn jemand wirklich nur aus
hobby seinen zehn stunden spielt dann
könnte es anders sein
weiß ich nicht es schwer ist gibt
sicherlich da auch leute die da durch
einsamen werden ja würdest du denn noch
so viel spielen wenn es nur hobby mehr
nein ich denke nicht sein also für mich
oder was mich immer so ins wort gehalten
hat ich habe letztens auch mal ein
bisschen darüber nachgedacht warum ich
das eigentlich so gern mache es ist
wirklich der wettkampf
man trainiert für ein bestimmtes event
man fährt hin man weiß der gegner hat
auch viel trainiert man weiß man dass
ungefähr auf einer höhe man trifft sich
dann spiel gegeneinander beide wollen
unbedingt gewinnen also wirklich dieser
dieser wettkampfcharakter hält mich im e
sport und ich würde definitiv nicht so
viel spielen wenn ich nicht aktiv werde
okay was ich noch festgestellt habe um
noch weitere nachteile sind
thematisieren da sind ja kaum mädchen es
sind viel mehr gebracht hat also war es
nur 13 es ist tatsächlich ja also es
sind fast nur männer also sportline sich
warum eigentlich unglaublich 99 warum
sind sie eben in den jugendzimmern und
kinderzimmer nur jungs wie das macht
nähe ich glaube es gibt auch viele
mädels spielen also es sind dann aber
einfach keine hieß bord gehen ist also
ich glaube viele mädels
einfach mal um das klischee auf dass er
überhaupt spielen sims oder wie heißt
das rudel jump ja da geht ich glaube es
gibt viele spiele und viele mädels die
auch zocken aber es gibt glaube ich nur
ganz ganz wenige die die starcraft 2
spielen oder vielleicht sagt greff zwei
aber wie sich wirklich dafür
interessieren was auf der turnier ebene
passiert also wenn die dann spielen
denke spielen sie mit zwei drei freunden
die vielleicht auch starcraft 2 spielen
aber wenig so die tour landschaft und
die mädels die auf events sind sind
meistens werden mitgebracht von ihren
freunden dann heißt es wahrscheinlich
kommen mal kurz mit ranzen soll ja und
ich denke teilweise lang weil die sich
danach schon sehr weil man ja als
außenstehender nicht wirklich viel
verstehen wie es bei dir ich habe eine
freundin wo hat sie kennengelernt
mehr oder weniger durch gaming nein also
nicht durch fachkräfte also sie kennt
sich in der szene aus sie spielt auch
aber kein starcraft 2 zumindest nicht
viel
und man hat sich dann sich über umwege
kennengelernt und
sie unterstützt mich auf jeden fall auch
sie guckt teilweise auch die streams und
versteht es ja ich denke natürlich nicht
so gut wie jemand der es halt viel
spielt aber doch durchaus sie weiß
ungefähr was los ist und was sagt sie
junge mach mal was vernünftiges ich will
irgendwann mal eine familien- oder das
tier nur machbar ist wenn ich so reicht
so weit sind wir noch nicht so wie ich
meine bis 24 da kann man ja ja habe ich
ja also ich selber habe noch keine
konkrete planung sie auch nicht und ich
glaube wir sind beide sehr zufrieden so
wie es im moment läuft also steht keine
keine änderung in sicht ok dann hoffe
ich dass sie weiterhin zufrieden bleibt
egal wie es sich entwickelt und soll für
welches etwas das nächste event die
deutsche meisterschaft geht wieder los
die saison startet wieder die apps jetzt
in kommender woche am montag laurich und
das ist auch dabei sein es findet erst
mal online statt also die polizei werden
online stattfinden und dann das finale
wird in köln sein
welches welche location weiß ich gerade
aber gamescom ist das nicht ist es wird
nicht auf der gamescom sein aber auf der
gamescom sind auf jeden fall auch
turniere ich glaube die haben also die
intel extreme masters ist ein bisschen
größer bisschen internationaler okay
also weder volk dankeschön danke und
nehmen diesen gefallen hat dem wird
sicher auch der mit sockel auch einem
der top spots gamer in deutschland
gefallen der sagt du brauchst
nervenstärke das erklärte er bei clixoom
und ansonsten kann ich auch empfehlen
den talk mit dem top schauspieler daniel
brühl der ein bisschen aus dem
nähkästchen der schauspielerei plaudert
und
erklärt warum schauspieler durchaus
eitel sein müssen also entweder was aus
dem schauspieler business oder was aus
dem gegner business auf jeden fall
inside ad hoc vom feinsten jahr und
ansonsten bis dann bekommt